how's it going ray my name is fear pack
it is time to finish Mac px yeah sorry
we got some I think you're like one lab
like cuz I don't know what the [ __ ] to
do that's just a problem it's this and
spits out what a tube freaking frickin
and here I don't know okay get Sam we
just make love this one looks different
so you click it and it's like oh nothing
happens I don't kiss Obama I just died
in my imaginations goes in great places
when I see that anyway uh we can take
this one is it's different
ah maladies yeah that should not change
anything what if we grab this one take
it here it doesn't work either take the
bomb oh no we're gonna get start to MEK
picks up selling skills / level 99 all
right what is he doing like Obama is
still there yeah yeah keep going
oh the White House is now happy Mac here
or there okay fine we got that one
thought I had this one there we go
thank God I don't know what I did there
friend's name of the house Mac me oh
yeah oh holy [ __ ] that was annoying okay
last one there
[Applause]
we blew up the bomb really all right
that was just painful painful I Thalia I
beat all the maps then I have this one
that will see if we unlock anything all
right
the gas station I haven't really tried
hard at these what about that maybe that
would do it ed we got a bonus best times
ever
I don't know what the hell to do why is
he humping that waiter yeah all right
this is me when I sleep I don't give me
[ __ ] all right let's give it a him thank
him I'll give it to that waiter then I'm
ready to take it well you take it how
about the Batman you're all fat
nice spin bra Wow what are you doing
back pixel is not pleased I don't know
if I saw I don't know what the [ __ ] out
okay let's take this and give it a her
here you go lady no I'm not that [ __ ] to
your pants it's not correct
all it did Pokemon one all right what
what happened all right let's give her
the Sun yet he became black people cool
okay
Pokemon to the date night how does he
you got to keep farting sound of it okay
let's give it a [ __ ] drain son nice
hats bro what
okay Pokemon to him z2 finds that it are
you doing right now
there we go there we go gotta catch'em
all
[Music]
last one that's fantastic
good job did you try the Thunder Wow
okay let's give this to up okay and try
that one it's 50 here wait what do you
do there and then oh thank you Mike fix
I'll keep doing what you're doing
everyone loves it okay excellent good
job Mike fix it okay this one yeah but
my crotch on fire
thank you for that and no I mean wow
Zeus was not happy by that one okay that
[Music]
one made sense get it dead I baked all
the maps now what how what get in all
rounds are you kidding me
in all rounds so many I can't do that
well it's sorry shifter one then I just
love that okay
all right I just had a ton of fun trying
to Hulk go down baby
I never mind I'll just kick yeah let out
of me that I represent overdone and now
this is hopefully unlike let me look at
what some of it in your match breast
this is awesome
don't worry excellent over nearly yet I
don't know if that's a good thing or not
but hey we have about it's a pretty cool
but this Titanic I descried the fishery
up and put it between her boobs God a
bad back pixel not even better
oh no see how it goes
ah star way cool
oh you gotta Archer d-does dick let's
get into Darth Vader are you good ok ok
oh it was a lightsaber of course I'm
sorry that was inappropriate
[Music]
ok it's an alien and a carrot
I think this carrot is more for my taste
there you go girl take the carrot solve
that know it in it god damn where does
this back Allah Jesus what are you doing
get off man take this drink ok I get it
he's spewing out worms green worms or is
he singing is it bad breath
that's uh
[Music]
of course that was I know
ok what is that USB stick
let's put in here fine let's put it here
that's it Solomon
god damn it all right oh [ __ ] I'm in
Wild West
let me just get that oh okay
thank you for that we're back at Titanic
Leo do something make your move man what
is this why not Oh like pixel what are
you doing that was amazing
Holli sure why didn't I think of that
next time we're steering towards an
iceberg I'll do that for sure
all right let's give this to our - Oh Jo
okay let's just hug the alien I should
not begin no no in the lava for wreck
pick so it turned his wheel does not
help us what about you what do you want
okay good job he has a boat again look
this up bang don't just stand there all
right let's take it
take your lightsaber and do your thing
Oh
[Music]
oh man for the lights every in your
mouth and [ __ ] fly away totally what
I was going for
oh it's almost fortunate I don't see the
Terminator there you go let's put in of
course I was still explode [ __ ] stick
the ring give it a hair - you want to
marry me and then she farts in mine
that's nice - last time I proposed just
kidding don't get we okay
Arnold I thought we've been through this
what about you do you want the ring do
you want to marry me
what if you keep farting what I want to
marry that okay
oh [ __ ] yep my hand is on fire son of a
[ __ ]
let's just go I love how huge I am
compared to the salon I don't shoot me
brah hey what about up here I just pick
on Arnold
did I do it yeah that was gold
I got gold [ __ ] I got gold okay know
what
no one's gonna propose to anyone god
damnit come on I can do it stop farting
on me
stop shooting a lot of little eyes
change I don't know what to do what is
what is stuff with the ring mind if I
click on the dynamite okay well I might
ideas what about the Sun here of course
[Music]
yeah okay that was pain in the ass but I
baked them on holy [ __ ]
anyway I can favorite if you enjoyed I'm
gonna unlock the other chef there's as
well of course sky Cobra day and I'll
see you next episode my ramen that can
you be quiet mom I don't need eat sorry
okay we're free